la pobreza y la falta de empleo impacto
en el hogar de leer y ramírez madre
soltera sus dos hijos mayores partieron
de forma ilegal a eeuu hace tres años
con la promesa de mejorar sus
condiciones de vida
el mayor me dijo una vez que han
aguantado la pobreza de trabajo
que se me dijo para sacarme adelante y
él me dijo mami me dio y lo primero que
voy a hacer al llegar a desmejorar su
casa alrededor de un millón de
hondureños ha emigrado en la última
década el 90% ha escogido eeuu como su
principal destino le di teme que sus
otros hijos sigan los pasos de sus
hermanos
la familia sigue creciendo y las
necesidades aumentan entonces ellos son
es decir para mí la verdad no me duele
porque
según el fondo hondureño de la deuda
externa y desarrollo de honduras las
cifras de pobreza del país se ubican en
74 por ciento y la pobreza extrema en
54%
eleconomista ismael cepeda opina que
será un reto para el nuevo presidente
lidiar con estos números y detener el
éxodo lastimosamente
la inmigración se ha convertido en un
flujo constante y ya va más allá también
de un tema económico va un tema
psicológico de desesperanza donde la
falta de oportunidades en nuestro país
por eso creemos que el próximo gobierno
debe tener una mirada integral a un
problema estructural que se ha
convertido la migración los candidatos
presidenciales únicamente han presentado
propuestas de campañas sociales
paliativas según los expertos ninguno de
ellos tiene una estrategia contundente
para mitigar la pobreza y de esa manera
evitar la salida de futuras caravanas de
emigrantes